hi everybody dr sammy here your friendly
neighborhood entomologist here to talk
to you about how adaptation which is
dependent on the environment responds in
context of environmental change
natural selection promotes adaptation in
populations it encourages populations to
develop traits that better allow
individuals to survive and reproduce
those adaptations are thus linked to the
environment in which they were forged
you can look at a lot of organisms and
based on their physical traits and or
their behavior you can tell what sort of
environment their population likely
evolved in
so adaptations are products of and are
inextricably connected to the
environment
but what happens when the environment
which forges a specific set of
adaptations no longer exists in that
form how do populations respond well
this happens to actually be a pretty
common occurrence on earth i wouldn't be
surprised if the saying things change
was first coined by a paleontologist
studying the history of life on earth
means you'd be well acquainted with the
dogged persistence of change well the
good news is the forces that drive
natural selection don't just disappear
when an environment changes
because of the persistence of heritable
diversity and differential survivorship
and reproduction natural selection is
still there to promote new adaptations
suited to the new environmental
conditions this means that when the
environment changes the distribution of
traits in the population will often
change as well
what those changes will ultimately be is
based on the adaptations promoted by the
previous environment and the pressures
presented by the new one so let's look
at some examples so i can make sure
you're picking up what i'm putting down
okay so
in evolutionary biology we like to
discuss three primary shift patterns
that can be observed as a result of
environmental change
directional selection
disruptive selection
and
stabilizing
selection
for each of these i'll show you a graph
and tell you a story of the stubbornness
and resilience of life
because every graph has a story
and the first of these stories is that
of directional selection the snow vole
is a mouse-like mammal that even i as an
admittedly bug-biased scientist
have to admit is pretty cute these
rodents are born at high elevations in
the swiss alps and researchers have
observed something that may seem obvious
on its face
large adult snow bowls have better
survivorship than smaller adult snow
bowls
they're more difficult for predators to
capture overpower and consume they have
greater temperature tolerance and
typically more fat stores for a long
winter so historically that distribution
of snowballs
bowls snow voles has been shifted toward
the higher end of the adult weight
spectrum
however climate change has led to
changes in the snow voles environment
snow has been falling earlier and
earlier in the alps giving the voles
less time to actually develop if the
voles haven't reached maturity by the
time the winter begins they typically
can't continue their life cycle
and because larger body sizes require
more time to develop there's a strong
selective pressure against the genes
underlying larger body sizes as the
environment shifts towards earlier
winter onset this also means that the
genes underlying smaller body sizes are
favored
so the smallest individuals in the
original population likely had the most
offspring and the variation in those
offspring likely included some that were
even smaller than in the original
population this means that as the
smallest individuals in each generation
continue to be favored and have the most
offspring the distribution of the
population will likely continue to march
to the left until it reaches a point
where the individuals are too small to
do well given the environmental
conditions this shift can be represented
by a graph that shows directional
selection
now let's go over the graph one more
time to make sure that everything is
clear here on the x-axis you'll see the
spectrum of average adult body size
ranging from the smallest to the largest
individuals traits are quite frequently
on a spectrum such that some individuals
possess a greater or lesser expression
and are thus differentially impacted by
environmental change on the y-axis is
the percent of individuals in the
population which allows you to see
proportionally how individuals fare by
comparison to those of greater or lesser
size the red arrow represents selection
pressure which in this case is imposed
by the abiotic factors of weather when
looking at these graphs you want to
consider who is least able to handle the
pressure imposed it's typically this the
area of the distribution where you'll
see the greatest difference between the
population before and after the
environmental change the white arrow
then shows which direction the
population as a whole is then shifting
directional selection events are those
which favor one extreme while excluding
another
however change itself can be as diverse
as the organisms it changes and thus you
can also get circumstances where
selection favors both extremes
this is called disruptive selection for
this example we look to the pungent
world of dung beetles
some populations of the beetle onto
phages accumenatis have a bimodal size
distribution where you'll see a large
number of large males in addition to a
large number of small males with very
few representatives of the sizes in
between
the large males use their superior size
strength and horns to fight other males
for the opportunity to mate
a male having selected a mate will spend
most of his time guarding the entrance
to the borough where she dwells
grappling with males of similar size who
challenge her challenge him for the
chance to depose him and mate with her
medium-sized males don't do well in this
context they they can't overcome the
larger males
but why then are there small males and
why are they so abundant in the
population well they've actually got a
trick up their sleeves
instead of trying to fight they forego
the battle entirely and simply use their
diminutive size to sneak past unnoticed
these small males typically lack horns
which leaves them similar in appearance
to females which makes male dung beetles
less inclined to engage them in battle
and the little guys further avoid
trouble by deftly digging a backdoor
entrance into the female beatles
subterranean nesting chamber such that
they rarely have to encounter the large
male guarding the front door this allows
them plenty of time to mate before
making their exit ensuring the
representation of their sneaky genetics
in the gene pool
disruptive selection selects for both
extremes on the spectrum to the
exclusion of the moderate trait in the
distribution but there's also a form of
selection that is the opposite of
disruptive selection
it's called stabilizing selection
stabilizing selection is observed under
circumstances where selection is
favoring the moderate set of traits in a
distribution to the exclusion of the
extremes for this story we once again
turn to the wondrous class insecta where
insects have learned to make a home in
some of the most ingenious ways possible
in the world of gall flies life begins
when a female gall fly lays an egg in
the stem of a suitable host plant the
developing larva induces the plant to
form a spherical growth around it called
a gall which protects the developing
fly's squishy body and provides it with
all the food it needs to reach adulthood
unless a parasitic wasp shows up and
attempts to lay eggs on the developing
gall fly
if this happens the developing wasp
kills the fly and takes over its living
space this is easiest to do with small
galls because the wasp has to stick his
thin egg laying tube through the gall to
access the developing fly a large gall
forms enough of a barrier between the
gall fly and the wasp's egg-laying tube
that it can't quite make it
so this selects for larger galls and
would promote directional selection all
other factors in the environment being
equal but
what happens when keen-eyed birds are
introduced well
large gulls become an easy meal for them
because they're conspicuous in the
environment this creates a situation
where small galls are selected against
as are large ones ensuring that the
medium-sized goals are favored
to remember what this distribution looks
like i tell myself that the trait
distribution is being stabilized by
pressure on both sides
environmental change can be pretty
diverse without the incredible adaptive
powers of natural selection our dynamic
world would be unsuitable for the
unpredictability that is
life as we know it